[Music]
simple
an absolute eater throughout the entire
tournament just eating them apart i call
simple the god of counter strike i call
him the greatest player to ever touch
the game he's hands down the best player
in the world so far this year you know
performances in tournament twins but
also in some of the losses for navi
the electronic for me is
like a good factor for flipside going
forward you know it's a young talent and
he's explosive he makes those impact
frags and he will get those entries in
these two players together have been so
consistent over the past few months like
they're both just dominant simple is
really a good player he's the best
player in the world and now i could be
better nip decide to rush into the bomb
site electronic with a good position
they line up oh my god fortunate for
electronic chris was switching he's
actually going to stick to the awp
surprisingly they want the double up set
up to go forward oscar's down chris is
on it he's going to finish the show
oh electronic shuts him down in the last
second completely surround him and tasia
gets the shot great mid-round calls from
big from guppy and now it's on to
electronics trying to isolate oh himself
here
he reads
is this the navi era now
yeah
[Music]
in order to understand how dennis
electronic cherupov went from living in
the shadow of one of the greatest
players cs go has ever seen
we need to go back in time a little bit
the year is 2015 and this scrappy stoic
stern faced teenager is trying to make a
name for himself in the mother of all
counter-strike obsessed regions
russia
the problem is that it's a lot more
difficult than you might think in spite
of its absurdly large player base russia
has always managed to play second fiddle
to other smaller eastern european
nations their one and only 1.6 major was
back in 2002 and the only russian to
ever earn such silverware in global
offensive is the x-god needless to say
electronic was facing a bit of an uphill
climb the only consistent championship
caliber roster the cis had ever produced
was the ukrainian super squad natas
vincere and he'd have to wade through a
sea of talented upstarts to catch their
attention advantage for
city players and actually wow double
kill by electronics
top top top
top he didn't understand where his
electronic guy an electronic poker face
still electronic wasn't your typical
up-and-comer he wasn't some cracked
g-fueled wild child who was cutting his
teeth in fpl two years after discovering
cs his tournament experience ran deep
given that he competed in his first 1.6
land at the age of 11. by 16 he boasted
not only crisp mechanics and a keen game
sense but calmness well beyond his years
even as he squared up against some of
his region's biggest names offline he
showed that he wasn't one to shy away
from a fight
ran bam
bam
and to watch a spray from electronic
unbelievable sprains by the end of 2015
electronic had gone from serving short
stints on a variety of semi-professional
sides to joining his first real roster
rebels a squad of rowdy up-and-comers
who were eventually signed by team
empire the man will have to clutch
and ace to win missing that first shot
not a good start and it's fixing
electronic the two players to watch out
for who just popped this round open
unfortunately the roster wasn't
particularly stable after failing to
make it to events for the better part of
a year they lost the support of their
org and were forced to continue their
struggle under the handle of nox soon
cow
and man was it a struggle finding one
more electronic he's got to go towards
the a site here i don't think he has the
time to do anything else he's gonna have
to find his kills very very quickly he
will manage to get the first msl is just
waiting and the second he goes for this
plan emerson's just gonna peek out and
finish off the game nice working thing
that has a much more convincing win and
that was the sort of map that we
expected to see from them earlier on and
yet in spite of his compatriots
floundering the end of 2016 saw
electronic catch the attention of blade
one of the cis region's greatest in-game
leaders and the very mentor who not only
discovered simple but helped turn him
into one of the most explosive talents
in the
[Music]
was offered a chance to follow in
simples footsteps and bring his talents
to flipside tactics there it is let's
have a look at the frags 15 for him
uh the new addition
for
it's uh is the hell raises flip side i
think it's
which
electronic electronic is new to flipside
that's right he's actually been pretty
cool recently yeah i've enjoyed watching
him and it was there with a stable squad
and a sound strategist that the cis's
second son really started to shine it's
all even once again and make that
equality going in favor of big for a
couple seconds before electronic puts it
in their favor leggy's only on eight
health not for too much longer flip side
will take a third when you can get
riflers out in open space like
electronic he's able to deliver for you
and again he's one of those young guys
we're keeping an eye on he's one of
those guys kind of in their high teens
that are just coming onto the scene and
this is kind of one of those tournaments
where he's trying to show you what he's
made of you know show that he has been a
great addition to flip five times i
think this has been a great roster move
for them funneling out a little bit but
still connects on to keep and blade will
be spraying down on the tabs and gets a
second kill leckie has gone down a flip
side have done it they will take it
install 2-0 16-11 on both maps you're
seeing some new talent rise up
electronic for me the mvp played a great
tournament blade leads the team well as
always before long electronic had
cemented himself as a stellar rifler
baiting out shots left him right where
lando will be spotted and postponed his
mark off what's happening he gets
himself a double electronic trade he
gets a spray down that's insane flip
side pick it up they're bringing it to
ot and all off the back of electronic
going absolutely crazy the thing is he
didn't even need to be holding a rifle
as long as he had some kind of weapon in
his hands
there was nothing he couldn't do and
sure enough this is jw's round three
kills per head they line up for
electronic though and a 1v2 and another
one 1v1
all of he knows exactly where electronic
is playing from electronic he's still
got nine bullets in the mag and will he
find the shot the pressure is on here
for olaf feister and old meister he's
down at 23 hp this is electronic
fighting for his team and he will get
the clutch at the end
unbelievable
still from the titillating one taps to
the stupidly salacious spray transfers
it was quickly becoming apparent that
the cis had stumbled upon its second
greatest superstar but electronic for me
is
like a good factor for flipside going
forward you know it's a young talent and
he's explosive he makes those impact
frags and he will get those entries and
win rounds like that's something that
flipside hasn't had in the past which
was perfect of course since as everyone
knows the actual greatest was an opera
double smokes in the same place they're
simple just jumping casually into the
side he's going to fall down and get out
there
from simple are you serious what is that
you're going through that simple that's
not allowed this is not fpl this is a
major given the cis struggles it didn't
take long for the community to start
wondering if and when the rowdy rifler
would finally get to join forces with
simple who'd been struggling to carry
na'vi
and they didn't have to wait long and
then caes wasn't happy with his
performance so he wanted to leave the
team and now they've brought electronic
so in this roster now with na'vi we have
electronic simple flamey zeus and edward
right navi had fielded one of the
greatest rosters ever to play 1.6 and it
spent virtually all of their time in
global offensive trying to reignite that
spark the issue is that aside from the
orcs fabled in-game leader zeus simple
hadn't been getting the help he so
desperately deserved what is it about cs
go right now that you feel like you can
just control it so well
i mean
it's
just it's easy you just need to practice
everything practice guns practice needs
practice team play practice everything
and you always should stay calm you
shouldn't let your emotions go up and go
down you should be on middle of this you
should have a good sleep shadow
everything you should have
good teammates i mean when you have a
great team it's uh a great captain of
course it's more easy to play for me
needless to say electronic was heralded
as being the solution to simple's
problem
when i joined tonight
okay it was my dream to join nalia so
it's really good to play
with
this with zeus simple and yeah i'm
really happy
the question was whether he'd be able to
deliver electronics still has this
teething period right he doesn't get to
play on many lands especially at this
level in the past has been with flipside
where he's been set up to be that star
or at least within a system where he
gets to shine a little bit more so here
he has to share some of that limelight
with the likes of simple we've just
touched on the exciting thing about this
navi roster is they have a lot of
firepower they have a trio they have a
call that could propel them into the top
five fortunately it didn't take long for
the prospect to prove his worth to na'vi
everything's just going horribly wrong
for mousesports here
seacoa
last man standing on this v bomb side
immediately dealt with by electronic and
perhaps all he can do is hope to get
really lucky through the smoke when a
set runs out of bullet the second
electronic pierced through the smoke
after entering dreamhack open winter
2017 as something of an unknown quantity
the resolute russian emerged from the
first land he'd ever played with na'vi
victorious and now stunning with his ump
maybe all that stands between larvae and
this entire tournament chris j
one on four 26 health for mastin and
simple takes in
navi are your champions
in an exquisite 2-0 performance and
throughout this entire event they look
strong electronic had a phenomenal best
of three though he was super solid but
then again you could say the same of
edward simple have great moments
everyone did play me as well
come 2018 and the year's first major in
boston it felt as if electronic could
really be the answer to simple's prayers
but despite dishing out stomps
throughout the event it wasn't enough
the shadow position he couldn't have
gotten to a main there wasn't enough
time and he would have heard him do so
he double checks to confirm this is
smart electronics gonna play his own
smoke against him he's gonna go exactly
where he just was so why why would he
check it but he's gotta make link he
goes back what a read from guardian as
he got time it sounds like he has his
guardian done it once again and found
match point he has
players remain zeus and simple hold on
to whatever they carry three shots great
read from zeus to hold off as well
because he knew ct was gone so the vent
was nest life left nes likely i should
say what a shot from guardian words out
of my mouth as he nails it through the
box he is tagged up smoke on the bomb
immediately he's got the kit doesn't
elect to hold on to it yet he's got time
to play with one and two for two smoke
will do it's phased to the final like
guardian is an absolute god
shortly after boston rumors that simple
was starting to lose faith in both his
roster and region at large was starting
to pick up steam the thing is had he
left nobody would have blamed him 2018
was the year that simple solidified
himself as the greatest competitor ever
to touch cs go and he was looking for a
roster worthy of his inhuman excellence
one with whom he could finally earn his
much coveted major title but as far as
electronic was concerned that roster was
navi being the loyal homebody that he
was simple made the fateful decision to
stay from there it was on electronic to
make good on his guarantee to step up
share the load and be the right-hand man
that his star fragger was in such
desperate need of and boy did he he's
gonna have to be flawless as nip decide
to rush into the bomb site electronic
with a good position they line up oh my
god that is just so fortunate for
electronic and he's going to finish it
off with class and style they're now on
the bottom trying to see if they can do
it such with a heroic save and ethan
takes one more down oh my god last
possible second electronic up on the
high ground he's not sure ethan he's
gonna win the round he saved them triple
kill chris was switched he doesn't he's
actually going to stick to the awp
surprisingly they want the double up set
up to go for it oscar's down chris is on
the smoke he's going to put
down
how
it
electronic shuts him down in the last
second and we go to a double overtime
situation my god how is this happening
by about midway through the year navi
had gone from consistently finishing the
top three to arguably the strongest
roster in the world
they'd taken home trophies at three
straight tournaments the last of which
was esl one cologne the so-called
cathedral of counter-strike means they
completely surround him and tamiya gets
the shot great mid-round calls from big
from guppy and now it's on to
electronics trying to isolate oh himself
he raises
it and an arc a power surge right
through two
but it's all done shortly as they wrap
around electronic fittingly finds the
last kill 16-8 navy will pick up finally
a trophy
they've been waiting for all year
it had also become clear that electronic
didn't see himself as the second fiddle
everyone made him out to be how do you
think how good is simple
simple is really a good player
he's my friend
he's
the best player in the world and now
i think i
i could be better than him
in the future like any world-class
competitor he yearned to call himself
the best and on literally any other
roster in the world he would be
but just not on this one unfortunately
for electronic he wasn't just
contemporaries with the greatest ever to
play the game
he was teammates with him friends
going into the year's second major in
london it felt as if na'vi had the star
power to reclaim their 1.6 glory the
problem is that cs go was entering its
most tyrannical era to date
come the grand finals navi found
themselves going up against the best of
that era and they never stood a chance
that's all that's left between australis
and the major simple on the high ground
with the season and surely he's going to
get taken out oh there's a gift he could
pick up an ak this might not be over yet
there's no kid though they've got to go
fast simple the second one they have to
keep going they've got to charge forward
he misses the jump flaming now with the
570s baiting the pair of short b is red
touching the bomb are they going to peek
holding it now and there is it it's just
out of flame it's not going to happen
astralis
[Applause]
[Music]
over the course of 2019 it became
increasingly clear that if navi were to
establish an era of their own they would
need more than star power
[Applause]
for zeus and is this man ever gonna win
a major the deep breath he got one with
gambit but will he get one with navi
that's what he's wanted he went back for
a reason but hence is gonna deny
the finns the kings and candidates
they're through
rosters like astralis and their american
imitators were reaching unprecedented
heights off the back of sound team play
soon it became apparent that simple and
electronic would need to step back take
the focus off of their own individual
play and put their faith into the full
five but first they needed to find the
right five with edward on the way and
zeus finally taking his much deserved
retirement it was on navi to usher in
the cis's newest generation of top tier
talent and teach them to perform on the
world's biggest stages of course that
would take time
20 seconds nrg need not peak he has to
plant a bomb let alone find these
players 15 seconds he's on the window
again no one needs to peek it only gets
worse and it's a 2-0 for nrg they've
taken the series versus navi
but then 2020 rolled around and
something changed with blade coaching
boomage coming into his own as an igl
and their largely unknown prospect
perfecto showing tons of promise navi
began to click like never before and
sure enough at iem katowice it all came
together this tournament so far when
fazer found the opening thing they've
only converted 33 percent of these
rounds we'll see if they can find this
pistol victory it's nico they can't get
a kill electronic as he gets his second
now tucking himself in colder will have
to step up electronic just picking them
off like it's no problem whatsoever
coldzera left towards long and that's
going to be it that's going to be the
ace
four electronics stepping up piece by
piece navi are finding this 16th round
no problem at all through the flames to
three or three 25 hp call it done and
there it is 1605 a very convincing 2-0
there the best-looking navi i've ever
seen against the world's number one team
there they made them look average they
made it look foolish at times and it's a
team effort as well this wasn't just a
simple show every single player on navi
showed up here in the semi-final two
versus two and it's going to be simple
and flamey who just seemed to be taking
matters into their own hands ladies and
gentlemen there it is your champions are
going to be rb it's a 3-0 clean sweep
here in the grand final this is a legit
team victory unlike anything the spodak
has seen before
nobody could touch them they did it in
the semi-finals and they did it again in
the grand finals your iem calavita 2020
champions it's normal
[Music]
unfortunately shortly after katowice the
onset of kova 19 took the entirety of
professional counter-strike online and
navi's rambunctious rise to the top was
unexpectedly cut short but it didn't
matter they'd finally hit the stride
they'd long been chasing and they knew
it i hope we're gonna be
one of the best teams in the world and
people will call it is this the na'vi
era now
i yeah
and sure the cis super squad proceeded
to fall into a bit of a slump but
electronic understood that the hard part
was over that all he needed to do was
bide his time and wait until things had
settled down and cs go was once again
his for the taking
because soon enough
it will be
soon enough electronic will stand at the
top of the counter-strike world not as
an overshadowed sidekick but a superstar
in his own right
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
[Music]
you